but he's my friend so was I captain
america civil war is almost here and
we're told it gets a little rough it
gets a little get so long heartbreak yes
so we asked Falcon himself anthony
mackie this are we still gonna get our
Falcon humor that we love I have to say
it's a real it's a very smart very
suspenseful movie but it's wildly funny
at the same time there's some like out
loud laughs in the movie is pretty cool
probably all coming from us but a few of
my ideas stuff that I didn't think would
make the movie and it made the movie et
was with Mackey and a chua tell Ejiofor
who recently joined the Marvel Universe
in Doctor Strange she was hell
officially welcome to the Marvel
Universe thank you you guys like if you
guys talked about it did you give money
advice for how to handle these crazy
crazy amazing passionate Marvel fans
hundred paint I gave him my essay when I
first got in a universe i wrote a small
10-page essay I gave it to him and I
hope it's been very helpful I think it's
been a terrific experience actually I
think there's something that's very
exciting brewing's